Welcome to the the date.
Today we're looking at, well,
one of the most striking
cultural shifts in recent
American politics.
It's this sudden pivot really
among the progressive
mainstream.
You know, for years, many
prominent voices, major cultural
players, they viewed the US
through this intensely critical
lens, talking about compromised
origins, systemic injustice,
even questioning the symbols
themselves.
Right, using terms like criminal
project or avoiding America
altogether sometimes.
Exactly.
And now Fast forward to today,
as we're heading towards the
250th anniversary America 250,
and there's this, well, this
concerted effort from many of
the same corners to embrace
patriotic language, national
symbols, even the founders,
albeit selectively.
The whiplash, as you said, it's
palpable.
Anti patriotic discourse one
minute, mandatory progressive
patriotism the next.
Which brings us right to our
central question.
How do we make sense of this?
Is this emerging progressive
patriotism a, shall we say,
calculated, maybe even cynical
bid for narrative control?
A patriotic heist?
Or is it something more like a
necessary act of national self
correction, an attempt to
genuinely reclaim the country's
founding promise for a, well, a
more equitable future?
I'm going to argue that this
shift is actually a pragmatic
and justifiable rehabilitation,
both politically and morally.
And I see it rather differently.
I think this whole rebrand is
fundamentally a, well, a
managerial oeration.
It feels engineered, built on
strategic calculation, maybe
even deceit, and lacking
crucially authentic belief in
the very symbols being Co opted.
OK, let me lay out my position
then.
My core idea here is that this
pivot isn't just cynical
maneuvering.
It's maybe a pragmatic, even
potentially regenerative
evolution.
It comes from realizing, perhaps
harshly, that just, you know,
pure moral scolding alone, it
can't hold a nation together in
the long run.
You could even argue that the
intense critique we saw was,
ironically, its own kind of
expression of love, or at least
a deep investment in an appeal
to the nation's unfulfilled
promise.
An appeal, OK.
Right.
So when progressives now try to
quote OWN 1776 and try to
reshape its meaning towards
greater equity, I think we
should see that as a legitimate
act of inheritance, not theft.
Patriotism doesn't have to be
the enemy of justice.
It can be, and perhaps must be,
the vehicle for achieving it.
The the suddenness that just
reflects an urgent strategic
awareness.
If we want to sustain the
Republic, especially heading
into something big like America
250, we have to adopt the
language of belonging, of common
identity.
It's the price, maybe, of
becoming effective stewards of
the nation's future.
That's a that's certainly a
strong case for political
necessity.
But my worry, my core objection
is that it this feels completely
divorced from any kind of
genuine moral discovery.
It doesn't feel like a change of
heart.
It feels like, well, like a
simulation basically constructed
by people who deep down maybe
still a harbor that same
fundamental dislike for the
country as historically
constituted, but now find
themselves in a political bind.
So my thesis is this, this new
patriotism, it's a short term
long con.
It's driven purely by the
immediate political situation.
It wasn't triggered by some
profound rethinking, but by the
sheer necessity of stopping the
other side from completely
owning the narrative.
Around the 250th anniversary and
this rebrand, it's being staged
very deliberately from above, by
what you might call the
managerial class, the
technocrats, the narrative
engineers the goal simply to
neutralize that damaging charge
of anti Americanism.
The result, though, feels kind
of well, the source material
uses the phrase Soviet in
texture, treating civic love
like it's just another variable
in behavioral engineering.
The real moral problem here
isn't change itself.
It's the perceived deceit, that
feeling that power is being
asserted, but it's all you know,
couched in kindness instead of
flowing from real belief in the
symbols they're suddenly waving.
OK, let's dig into that charge
of deceit because I think
perhaps it misunderstands how
political language actually
works, especially in a climate
like ours, so polarized.
You're saying this new
patriotism lacks authenticity
because, well, the same people
who were denouncing the Founders
are now what, invoking Madison
to defend democracy?
You're suggesting the public has
a finely tuned radar for fakery
and you just can't rebrand
conviction?
Absolutely.
The whole thing seems focused on
optics over conviction.
That's the critical failure when
elites try to just borrow
language that they previously
rejected.
It comes across as a
performance, like a conditional
acceptance asking the nation to
love itself, but only on these
pre approved, supervised terms.
It's the sincerity that's just
missing if the architects of
this still seem intellectually
uncomfortable with or even
hostile to the country's
historical framework, when no
amount of slick marketing is
going to create genuine
affection.
And I think the political
fallout from that kind of
visible hypocrisy could be
pretty severe.
See, my issue with that view is
that it holds political action
to an almost impossible standard
of pure authenticity, especially
in mass politics.
Does strategy always have to
spring from some perfectly pure,
unmanaged emotion?
I mean, societies evolve.
Political language has to
evolve, right?
If it doesn't, it calcifies.
So this attempt to make
patriotism more inclusive, to
define the nation by its
potential for justice, not just
its past sins, I think that's
inherently positive, even if the
initial push was, well,
managerial or strategic.
Political rhetoric often starts
a strategy, doesn't it?
A means to an end.
And then through practice,
through repetition, it can
become genuinely shared belief.
Possibly over time, but.
And think about the alternative.
What's the alternative?
Just seed all patriotic
language, the entire narrative
of the Republic?
To the populist right?
That seems strategically
disastrous and frankly,
detrimental to the nation
itself.
So the utility of adopting the
language of our Republic, making
it speak to today's struggles,
economic, social, whatever, I
think that utility simply
outweighs the charge that it's
instrumental.
Political actions ultimately are
judged by their results and a
more inclusive patriotism.
That seems like a worthwhile
result, even if the initial
spark was, let's say, strategic
necessity.
I understand the pragmatism
argument, I really do, but
sacrificing sincerity for
utility feels like a dangerous
trade off in the long run.
It erodes the kind of moral
capital a Republic needs, and I
think the comparison to past
patriotic moments really
highlights this this managerial
problem.
Think back to 1976.
The vicentennial.
People describe that as a kind
of spontaneous carnival of
belief.
It was messy, loud, maybe a bit
tacky, sure, but it felt like it
came genuinely from below.
Today's effort feels well
engineered, inorganic.
OK, I see the contrast you're
drawing, and yes, the difference
is quite stark.
The populist right today
certainly channels some of that
messy, loud, unfashionable
America vibe.
It's often coarse, even vulgar,
as the source material notes.
But then you look at this new
progressive patriotism with its
careful messaging, its diverse
models, its approved slogans,
and this undeniable undercurrent
of maybe moral condescension
towards the actual historical
American experience.
It just doesn't feel
spontaneous.
Like 76.
It feels like you said focus
grouped, maybe outsourced.
In that right there is where the
moral argument gets really
interesting for me.
Because while the populist right
might be coarse, self
interested, and frequently
vulgar, as the text puts it,
there's a kind of vulgar
transparency to it that might
actually be, in a strange way,
morally clearer.
It's legible.
You know what you're getting.
It's about appetites, it's about
loud self-interest.
It's not really pretending to be
this detached moral guide or
curator of the national spirit.
Legible in its coarseness.
Exactly.
Whereas the progressive elites
approach often involves a sense
of nudging, steering, trying to
manage citizens for their own
good, and that impulse to
control the narrative rather
than genuinely persuade people.
That feels like the real
betrayal of something deep in
America's cultural DNAI mean,
isn't the Republic partly
founded on skepticism, towards
centralized moral authority?
On a kind of rugged
individualism that prefers, you
know, plain speech even if it's
uncomfortable, over polished
choreography?
The idea that a select few can
sort of dictate the proper terms
of civic affection and engineer
the correct way to be patriotic.
That's where that Soviet and
texture feeling comes from.
It treats citizens less like
participants and more like
subjects whose attitudes need
managing for some higher
ideological purpose.
But you seem to be elevating
transparency, no matter how
crude or frankly, divisive.
It's content above the strategic
need for civic cohesion.
And I think that's a risky move
when the very identity of the
Republic is being fought over.
If the definition of the nation
is up for grabs, just abandoning
the language of national
belonging because adopting it
might involve some temporary
political stagecraft seems self
defeating.
If we just let messy, vulgar
transparency run wild and
monopolize the whole discourse,
don't we risk just fragmenting
completely civic identity?
Especially in a huge diverse
country like this?
It needs some cultivation, some
shared symbols, which almost
inevitably requires a degree of,
well, management.
Perhaps, but let's shift to the
words themselves, because this
is where the heist accusation
feels sharpest, the way
historical terms are being
ideologically repurposed.
Right.
Talk about that.
We'll look at how the American
Revolution itself is being
essentially recast as a kind of
left wing prototype.
The idea of no kings, for
instance, suddenly gets
reinterpreted to mean no
billionaires or freedom from
tyranny, which historically was
about freedom from arbitrary
government power, about
establishing ordered liberty
that gets twisted into freedom
from tradition or freedom from
economic inequality.
I think this does real violence
to the language because it
drains these revolutionary
concepts, other specific
original meanings, and just
refills them with contemporary,
often vague managerial jargon.
It feels like intellectual
counterfeiting, really making
the past just a convenient
mirror for today's political
wish list.
OK, that's a very fairpoint
about semantic drift, about how
meanings change.
But I'd argue that this process
of reinterpretation is actually
a form of legitimate
inheritance.
It's the ongoing intellectual
struggle over what a nation's
founding means.
Political language, especially
the language of revolution and
founding.
It's always dynamic.
It has to be right.
It needs to evolve to speak to
current crises.
Otherwise it just becomes
irrelevant.
A museum piece.
So yes, maybe the Founders are
tolerated now primarily as quote
flawed dreamers whose unfinished
work conveniently resembles the
Democratic Party platform.
Conveniently, yes.
But.
But this reinterpretation might
be necessary to keep the
Republic's founding promise
alive and relevant today,
connecting that original fight
against hierarchy in 1776, the
arbitrary power of a king, to
modern forms of inequality,
whether economic or social.
That isn't necessarily theft.
It's drawing a line, connecting
past to present to drive what I
called self correction.
We're not appealing to the
founders perfection, obviously
not, but to the promise embedded
in their words and actions.
If you freeze the meaning of
revolutionary language in 1776,
you're basically saying the
nation's moral and intellectual
journey is over, and it clearly
isn't.
I'm sorry, I just, I still don't
quite buy that this
reinterpretation is just a
benign update, because that
logic seems to ignore the pretty
profound conceptual shifts
involved.
The founders, even the most
radical, they generally defined
patriotism as loyalty to a
system, self rule protected by
law.
This structure of ordered
liberty that limited both state
power and pure popular impulse.
The current progressive
reframing, though, often defines
patriotism more as a kind of
moral duty, curated from the top
by this managerial class we've
discussed.
OK.
So the result is revolutionary
language gets twisted to justify
forms of top down social or
economic control, which feels
fundamentally anti revolutionary
in spirit.
Saying no kings means no
billionaires isn't just updating
language, it's swapping a fight
against the nature of arbitrary
political power for a fight
against certain economic
outcomes.
It drains the language of its
core focus on individual
political liberty and replaces
it with a collectivist ideal of
managed welfare that feels like
the ideological hijack is
complete, using the language of
freedom to potentially justify
more institutional control, not
less.
That really brings us back to
the tension between expediency
and principle, doesn't it?
But look, regardless of how pure
we judge the motives to be, the
strategic effect is what
ultimately matters for the
nation.
This pivot, OK, maybe it was
sudden, maybe calculated, but it
allows progressives to finally
wield patriotism as a potent
vehicle for justice.
It lets them argue, convincingly
perhaps, that demanding a more
equitable Republic is an appeal
to America's highest promise,
not a rejection of it.
This adoption of the language of
belonging, however, and
perfectly it began.
That's how a nation evolves, how
it repairs itself.
It's about ensuring the next 250
years are better, more inclusive
than the last.
And I have to reaffirm my view
that this current rebrand feels
like a performance.
It substitutes, as the source
suggests, faith with
performance, conviction with
optics.
And the ultimate danger to the
Republic might not be any
specific ideology, but the
normalization of hypocrisy as a
political strategy.
You can't really steal belief,
you can only mimic it.
And eventually that mimicry
shows.
And it further erodes the civic
trust that any shared national
project desperately needs to
survive.
So it sounds like we certainly
agree on one thing.
The upcoming America 250
anniversary is shaping up to be
a major referendum on
authenticity.
This whole tension between what
might be sincerely believed and
what is strategically necessary,
that's clearly going to keep
shaping how Americans try to
define their country.
Indeed, it really forces a
choice, doesn't it?
Or at least forces us to weigh
the options.
Is it the demand for absolute
candor, even if messy?
Or is it the perceived necessity
of political maneuvering to
reach certain goals?
The listener, I suppose, has to
decide which approach the
polished, perhaps managerial
performance aimed at
neutralizing opponents, or the
louder, maybe messier belief
rooted in transparency.
Which one will ultimately last
longer and better sustain the
Republic?
There's definitely a lot more to
today.
We are wrestling with a question
that feels particularly pointed,
maybe even a bit uncomfortable.
Yeah, definitely touches a
nerve.
It's about what happens when the
language of national affection,
you know belonging isn't treated
as genuine belief, but more like
like a product that needs an
urgent, high stakes rebranding.
And what's really striking here
based on the source material
we're looking at, is just the
sheer speed of the shift they
describe.
We're diving into a source that
makes this really massive claim
that a significant chunk of the
American cultural elite who the
source identifies as the
progressive managerial class,
that they've recently
engineered, something the source
calls the Great Patriotic Heist.
The.
Great patriotic heist.
OK, let's definitely unpack
that.
So our mission today is to
analyze this very provocative
claim.
It is provocative.
The idea that this recent,
seemingly calculated pivot from
rejecting American National
identity to fiercely
appropriating it, that this move
is purely strategic.
Driven by politics, not
conviction.
That's the core assertion.
Exactly.
And lacking any like, you know,
true belief.
It's a claim that if you take it
seriously, it really does
reshape how you might see the
current political moment.
Absolutely, yeah.
Think about the starting point
the source lays out just 18
months ago, maybe two years.
Not long ago at all.
The cultural mainstream and
we're talking, you know, major
newspapers, universities,
cultural institutions was pretty
consistently talking about EU s
s well, a criminal project.
Founded in oppression,
structural racism.
That was the dominant narrative
in those circles.
Right flags were often seen or
presented as symbols of shame.
The 4th of July, often framed as
a day for lamenting historical
injustice, empire, things like
that.
And then boom, the whiplash as
the source calls it.
The speed is really key to their
argument.
It seems critical.
Almost overnight, the same
commentators, the same
institutions, suddenly
rediscover this vocabulary of
belonging.
Yeah, they start using phrases
like our Republic, emphasizing
the promise of America language
that might have seemed well
dated or even problematic to
them just much before.
And this sudden transformation,
the source argues, that's what
we need to focus on.
Why did it happen?
And why do they insist on
calling the result, this new
patriotism, a kind of fraud?
Or moral theater.
That's another phrase they use.
It implies performance over
substance.
Moral theater, OK, It suggests a
deep suspicion of motives,
doesn't it?
Completely.
The source argues that
patriotism for this specific
group just became a necessary
rebranding exercise, almost a
defensive maneuver.
So less about love of country
and more about brand management.
Exactly.
An engineered marketing campaign
launched, they claim, by people
who previously viewed the nation
with pretty profound structural
skepticism.
The source seems to be saying,
you know, every era cooks up its
own kind of political deceit.
And ours specializes in this
kind of managed, highly
performative moral signaling.
That's the argument.
OK, so this is the core tension
we need to hold onto throughout
this deep dive, right?
What actually happens when
patriotism gets outsourced?
When it's focus groued, manage
from the top down.
Instead of bubbling U from the
bottom, you know, spontaneously,
organically, as just an
expression of belonging.
That's the heart of this great
patriotic heist claim.
And maybe we should quickly
clarify who the source means by
the progressive managerial
class.
It's important.
Good point.
Who are they talking about
specifically?
They define it as the educated
professional elite.
So people managing cultural
institutions, running university
administrations, foundation
boards, major newsrooms,
corporate DEI offices.
Good keepers, the ones who
shaped the narrative.
Essentially, yes.
The ones who control cultural
perception, or at least try to.
It's not necessarily about, say,
grassroots activists on the
street.
Got it.
That distinction feels crucial.
It's about institutional power.
Precisely OK.
So to really get why this claim
feels so intense, why the source
uses language like heist and
fraud, we probably need to
ground ourselves a bit in the
history.
Because American patriotism.
It hasn't exactly been static,
has it?
Not at all.
That's a critical piece of the
setup for their argument.
Patriotism has always shifted,
you know, depending on what the
country was fighting for or
maybe fighting against.
Right.
So like the founding period, say
1776 through the 1820s.
Back then, the source argues,
patriotism was really quite
intellectual.
It wasn't about blind loyalty to
a king or some shared ethnicity.
It was loyalty to an idea.
Self rule, Individual liberty.
Exactly.
And fundamentally it was about
rebellion.
Rebellion against imperial
management, against centralized
hierarchy.
It was actually anti
establishment in a way.
OK, but that idea had to evolve,
right?
This nation grew and faced
crises.
Oh, massively.
The Civil War forced a huge
redefinition.
Suddenly, patriotism wasn't just
about an idea, it became about
devotion to the Union.
Preserving the nation itself.
Yes, but not just
geographically.
It became tied to moral
progress, specifically the fight
against slavery.
The nation had to sort of earn
its continued existence by
addressing that original sin.
Then things shifted again, maybe
towards the state in the early
20th century.
Definitely the Progressive Era,
the world wars.
You see patriotism becoming much
more about collective duty,
sacrifice, loyalty starts
getting equated with the growing
power of the state.
That's when you get things like
the income tax, national parks,
yeah, big federal projects.
Right.
And these expansions of central
power were often wrapped in this
sense of like, unnecessary civic
religion.
It became about what you owed
the nation collectively.
But that kind of consensus, that
almost blind faith you didn't
last forever, Vietnam seems like
a major breaking point.
Absolutely shattered it.
The source material really
highlights Vietnam as the first
time anti patriotism, or at
least deep skepticism about
national motives truly enters
the mainstream discourse.
Protest cynicism about
authority.
Yeah, the idea that the
government was inherently good
or always right, that really
took a beating.
It never fully recovered in some
ways.
And that skepticism, according
to the source, just got deeper
and deeper, especially by the
late 2010's.
Dramatically so.
You saw intellectual and
academic discourse deliberately
blurring the lines between
patriotism and nationalism, and
nationalism was increasingly
framed as inherently dangerous.
You know, a slittery slope to
something ugly.
So this is the period the source
is really focusing on leading up
to the alleged heist, when
dissent became almost the
default stance in some elite
circles.
Exactly when the core identity
of the nation itself was
frequently being questioned,
critiqued, even rejected.
You see it in the language.
They point to terms like
colonizer becoming common not
just historically, but applied
to contemporary figures.
Right, or the use of turtle.
I like the indigenous name for
North America.
Using it symbolically was a way
to reject colonial names, reject
established authority, showing a
really profound break with the
conventional narrative.
OK, so that context is crucial.
It sets up this stark contrast
the source makes to really
hammer home the scale of the
alleged fraud.
Yeah, 1976 versus 2026.
Yeah, the bicentennial versus
the upcoming semi
quincentennial.
Let's talk about 76 first.
The Bicentennial, 200 years.
From the descriptions, it sounds
like Yeah, well, pure unmanaged
chaos in a good way.
Kind of.
It's described as this
delirious, almost kitschy wave
of civic self love.
And the key thing It wasn't
organized from Washington DC.
It just happened everywhere
like.
Gas stations selling red, white
and blue stuff?
Yeah, small town parades popping
up.
Exactly.
Thousands of them.
And the source really emphasizes
its authenticity.
They see it as this moment of
genuine, almost collective
therapy after the traumas of
Vietnam and Watergate.
Spontaneous Main St.
PTA bake sales.
Maybe some questionable folk
art?
Totally gaudy?
Maybe, but real?
There was no corporate sponsor
shaping the message, no
algorithm driving the sentiment.
It came entirely from below.
And that very spontaneity, that
lack of control, the source
argues.
That's what unnerves the
contemporary managerial class.
Precisely.
They quote something like
unregulated affection for
country looks like a crowd they
can't choreograph.
It's messy, unapproved, maybe
even a little embarrassing to
sophisticated tastes.
OK.
So contrast that feeling, that
grassroots explosion, with what
the source anticipates for
America 250 in 2026.
It's night and day.
According to them, the
bicentennial was this sprawling,
messy carnival of belief.
America 250.
The source says it's already
shaping up to be a highly
managed, carefully staged
marketing campaign.
Orchestrated from above.
Yes, planned, curated, focus
grouped.
The whole atmosphere feels
different, prepackaged.
And this difference unmanaged,
maybe slightly tacky populist
pride versus managed, sleek top
down symbolism that's central to
the heist argument.
Absolutely crucial.
It sets the standard.
If the feeling in 1970s thought
was real, then the planned
feeling for 20 76 must be, by
their definition, engineered a
counterfeit.
We have to keep that baseline in
mind, that it explains the
strength of the language, the
accusation of fraud.
They aren't just disagreeing
with the message, they see the
whole delivery mechanism as
fundamentally fake.
Fake in the sense that it's
designed to mimic that 76
feeling, but without any of its
complexity.
It's grassroots energy.
It's, well, it's authenticity.
Which brings us right to the
motive.
If it's a heist, why do it?
Why would this cultural elite,
the same group the source claims
previously scoring the flag,
suddenly launched this massive
rebrand?
The source material doesn't
mince words here.
The motive, they claim, was pure
control, not some moral
epiphany, not a genuine change
of heart.
Control.
Control driven entirely by
political necessity, by
circumstance.
It's fundamentally about
securing and maintaining their
cultural gatekeeping authority.
That's the argument from the
source.
Their role as the shapers of
cultural perception.
Exactly.
And the specific circumstance,
the threat they proceed, was
incredibly specific.
It revolved around the potential
return of Donald Trump to the
presidency.
OK, so the argument is a Trump
return.
Change the calculus.
Completely, according to the
source, they state that a
potential second Trump
presidency would have given him
de facto authorship over the
entire 250th anniversary
celebration.
Meaning he would control the
narrative, the parades, the
speeches, the whole tone.
Everything The official story of
America at its 250th birthday.
And for the cultural
establishment, as the source
portrays them, this was an
existential threat.
The threat to their narrative.
The threat that he would
effectively own the story of
America itself.
If Trump claimed patriotism
loudly and unapologetically, the
narrative they've been building,
America as fundamentally flawed,
oppressive, would be sidelined,
replaced by his version.
Maybe America First
triumphalism.
So the only way to stop?
That was to launch an immediate
counter narrative to seize the
symbols themselves.
The establishment, the source
claims, could no longer afford
the intellectual luxury of
mocking the flag or discepting
the founding.
They had to appropriate it.
Use the flag to beat him to the
punch, essentially.
It became a political necessity
claim, the symbols of
patriotism, to deny them to
their chief political opponent.
That's the raw political
calculation the source
describes.
OK, I have to jump in here.
Calling it a heist implies, you
know, deliberate malice, total
cynicism.
Yeah.
Is the source giving any room at
all for the possibility that
maybe?
Yeah.
Maybe some of these elites
genuinely had a change of heart.
That's a really fair question.
Or maybe just realize that
constantly attacking the
national identity, regardless of
the country's flaws is just bad
politics.
Yeah, and culturally
unsustainable.
Maybe some actual self
correction is happening?
It's a critical point to raise.
The source is highly skeptical
of good faith motives here.
They might concede that the need
for some kind of unifying
national identity is real, maybe
even belatedly recognized.
But they see the timing, the
suddenness and the texture, the
specific way this new patriotism
is performed, as overwhelming
evidence of manipulation, not
sincerity.
The texture being that managed
feeling we talked about.
Exactly.
They view it as what they call a
short term long con, a focused,
maybe 2 year marketing Sprint.
But what goal?
The sole purpose, they argue, is
to neutralize the political
optics.
The charge of being anti
American just long enough to
define the 250th anniversary on
their own terms and maintain
control of the narrative.
OK, so if the motives is
presented as political and
managerial, how does the
strategy actually work?
How do you reframe patriotism so
quickly?
Well, according to the source,
it requires fundamentally
rewriting 1776 itself.
Rewriting the American
Revolution.
For framing it, the source
describes how the revolution is
now being actively presented in
these circles as a kind of left
wing prototype, a populist
uprising against hierarchy.
Said of the more traditional
story, ordered liberty,
constitutionalism, checks and
balances.
Right.
Less about structure, more about
identity and hierarchy.
It gets reframed as primarily an
identity revolution almost
rather than a political or
structural 1.
And how does the language get
repurposed?
The source mentioned semantic
hijacking.
Yes, that's central to the
strategy they describe.
It's where the actual words and
phrases of the revolution are
systematically sort of emptied
of their original classical
meanings.
And then refilled.
And then refilled with
contemporary, often managerial
or therapeutic jargon.
The source gives some pretty
potent examples.
Like what?
Take the foundational slogan No
Kings.
Simple enough, right?
In 1776, that meant rejecting
the divine right of monarchs,
establishing popular
sovereignty, feeling unchecked,
centralized power.
OK.
Standard understanding.
Today, the source argues, No
Kings is being subtly reimagined
and used almost as shorthand for
No Billionaires.
Wow, that's quite a leap.
It's a huge ideological shift,
right?
It equates modern economic
inequality, however extreme,
with 18th century hereditary
monarchy.
It detaches the language from
constitutional structure and
applies it purely to, say,
economic or social resentment.
So the critique shifts from
structure and power to wealth
and distribution using the same
historical words.
That's the claim.
Similarly, they argue, freedom
from tyranny gets subtly morphed
into something closer to freedom
from tradition.
So liberation from social norms
establish morality rather than
just political oppression.
Exactly.
The powerful, stirring language
of independence is still used,
but its target shifts inward
towards cultural constraints
rather than external political
control.
What about the Founders
themselves?
They're awkward figures in this
kind of reframing, aren't they?
You can't just ignore them.
No, you can't.
So the source says they're now
sort of tolerated, but
conditionally they're no longer
just denounced as slaveholding
hypocrites, which was arguably
the previous dominant critique
from this managerial class.
So how are they presented now?
They get reframed as flawed
dreamers, visionaries whose
hearts were in the right place
but whose unfinished work just
happens to align perfectly with
the current progressive
political platform.
It's like an ideological
adoption.
So the revolutionary language
gets recycled, but it's floating
in.
What do the source call it?
A semantic fog?
It's.
A semantic fog of therapeutic
inclusivity.
Yeah, it's designed to be
slightly confusing, but
strategically useful.
And the immediate goal, the
practical point of all this
linguistic maneuvering.
According to the source, it's
simply to neutralize that
damaging anti American charge
just long enough to get through
the America 250 anniversaries
even without Trump or his allies
owning the patriotic narrative.
Survive the anniversary.
Survive the anniversary and
maintain their cultural
gatekeeping authority.
Secure the brand before the
competition can claim it.
That's the cold strategic read
from the source.
It sounds exhausting, honestly,
both to perform and to walk.
And that exhaustion, that sense
of performance, brings us right
to the core moral argument.
The source makes the difference
between genuine belief and
simulation.
The Achilles heel of the whole
operation, they claim, is what
the public's BS detector.
Essentially, yes.
What they call the American
public's radar for fakery.
And that radar, the source
argues, is going off like crazy
right now.
Blaring loudly, they suggest,
because this new progressive
patriotism feels less like
genuine affection and more like
a carefully constructed
simulation.
It feels like patriotism
authored by people who maybe
still deep down, don't actually
like the country they're
suddenly professing to love.
Is that the idea?
That's the core accusation, and
the evidence they point to is
the tone.
The tone.
How so?
It's not joyous, it's not messy,
it's not visceral or passionate,
It's relentlessly managerial.
Managerial patriotism?
What does that even feel like?
The source uses some pretty
cutting analogies.
It feels like the tenderness of
an HR department, or like a
hostage negotiation, where the
nation is being told it must
love itself, but only under
strict supervision, with lots of
approved language and constant
reminders of its flaws, with
disclaimers attached.
I can always picture that it's
the opposite of like a
spontaneous pub sing along of
the national anthem.
It's a structured meeting with
talking points and diversity
checklists.
Exactly, you nailed it.
The source really hammers this
idea that the required
enthusiasm feels outsourced,
like they're beta testing
patriotism as a concept on the
country.
And you see the same patterns
across elite messaging
campaigns.
Approved slogans carefully,
diverse models in the imagery,
the constant celebration of
consensus, and what the source
describes, quite pointedly, as
the faint odor of moral
condescension.
The elite guiding the poor,
misguided country toward a
healthier, more approved view of
itself.
That's the vibe they detect, and
they compare this whole approach
to creating a consumer product.
Right.
Patriotism is a lifestyle brand.
Yes, focus grouped into
something sterile, red, white
and algorithmic.
Blue is the phrase they use and
the killer analogy the.
Plant based meat.
One, that's the one.
This new patriotic fervor is the
cultural equivalent of plant
based meat, engineered to mimic
the flavor of something real
without any of the moral
cholesterol.
Oof.
That's brutal, but potent.
It really lands, doesn't it?
It suggests patriotism stripped
of all the difficult,
complicated, sometimes ugly,
organic stuff of a real nation.
And Polish to the smooth,
sterile Sheen of acceptable
managed virtue.
Exactly.
So if that's the case, if it
feels so managed and artificial,
how does the source explain why
this style seems to be
struggling, especially when
contrasted with the populist
right specifically, you know,
Trumpism?
Does the source romanticize
Trumpism then?
Not at all.
They are very clear about its
flaws.
They describe it as coarse,
vulgar, often self interested,
maybe greedy, certainly
shameless a lot of the time.
OK, sounds critical.
It is but, and this is the
crucial distinction they make,
it is legible.
Legible.
What do they mean by?
That they mean it's motivations,
even it's vices are pretty much
on on the table.
It's a creature of appetite, of
ambition, of wanting power and
recognition.
There's not a lot of subtext or
hidden motive.
You kind of know what it wants.
OK, it's blunt.
It's blunt, and this legibility,
this lack of pretense,
surprisingly grants it a kind of
moral advantage in the sources
critique of the managerial
class.
So are they saying bluntness is
better than manipulation?
Essentially, yes.
The source frames it like this.
The populist right basically
says yeah, I want the gold tower
and the big parade, and I don't
really care what you think about
it.
Okay, correct.
While the managerial left in
this analysis says we're only
seizing control of the narrative
and managing your patriotism for
your own good, we're doing it
kindly to help you.
And for a culture that's
supposedly prizes straight talk,
maybe even distrust smooth
talkers.
The first one, however offensive
you might find its goals, feels
in its sheer directness maybe
more American, or at least less
deceptive than the second.
That's the argument.
So the core critique is that the
managerial left wraps its power
plays in the language of
kindness, nudging, steering,
helping the country understand
itself through social
engineering.
Right.
And this perceived manipulation,
this polite deceit, is viewed by
the force as fundamentally more
corrosive, maybe morally
inferior to just rude honesty,
because manipulation is harder
to identify and fight than open
ambition or even open vice.
It's the instinct to manage, to
guide, to correct, rather than
just persuade or argue.
That's what gives this new
patriotism it's unsettling feel.
That's what the source argues
makes it feel Soviet in texture.
Not communist, obviously, but
relying on civic love as a form
of behavioral engineering.
Trying to replace organic faith
with prescribed performance.
Replacing conviction with a
focus group consensus.
It sounds like the age-old
problem of hypocrisy.
The Puritans feared it as a sin.
The source seems to argue our
modern elites have turned it
into a political strategy.
That's a great way to put it.
And this strategic hypocrisy,
this managed approach, leads
directly to why the source
thinks it fundamentally clashes
with, well, with America's
cultural DNA.
The operating system rejects the
patch idea.
Exactly.
That's such a powerful analogy
they use trying to run
Scandinavian social democracy on
frontier software.
OK.
Can you flesh that out?
What is the source mean by
Frontier software or this
American cultural DNA?
The core argument is that the
US, historically and culturally,
was built by people who were
almost by definition risk
takers, gamblers even.
People who left everything
behind rolled the dice.
Right, people who often failed,
sometimes dramatically, before
maybe succeeding.
The source calls the US an
almost embarrassingly sink or
swim country.
Which sounds inherently
resistant to collectivist
management.
Deeply resistant.
It's a culture, the source
argues, that doesn't primarily
venerate the vulnerable or the
collective in the way some other
societies might.
It celebrates the stubborn
survivor.
The individual who picks
themselves up stands their
ground.
The theology is less Blessed are
the meek and more.
More Get back up, dust yourself
off and try again.
Maybe even Don't Tread on me.
And how does that translate into
a moral code that pushes back
back against this managerial
impulse?
It fosters a deep seated value
for standing your ground,
protecting what's yours
physically and metaphorically,
and crucially trusting your own
judgement over some committees
consensus or a bureaucrats
guidance.
The basic temperament just
rejects being handled.
Does the source give an example
of this?
They use a pretty stark 1 the
cultural resonance of
self-defense.
They argue that shooting an
intruder who breaks into your
home in the American cultural
context, it often transcends
legal debate.
It becomes symbolic.
It's a parable of sovereignty.
They say self-defense acquires
this moral grandeur because it
embodies that ultimate
individualistic imperative.
Trust yourself.
Protect your sphere.
Don't wait for the committee to
approve.
OK, so the attempt to graft this
layer of collectivist virtue of
managed emotion and prescribed
behavior onto this fiercely
individualistic, self reliant
temperament, it's failing.
It's like an organ transplant
rejection.
According to the source, the
system fundamentally rejects the
managerial patch.
Americans, they insist, will
forgive a hustler long before
they forgive a handler.
Because the handler implies
condescension control.
Exactly.
The source maintains that the
managerial class fundamentally
misreads the countries energy.
They think America yearns for
instruction for therapeutic
guidance.
When really the default is
suspicion of anyone trying to
control the narrative or manage
feelings.
That's the argument.
Suspicion of control runs deeper
than the desire for guidance.
But here's a twist.
Maybe the source points out a
danger for the engineers of this
so-called heist, right?
The language itself is powerful.
Yes, this is a fascinating
paradox.
They identify when you
strategically start using terms
like defend democracy, invoking
James Madison, or you readopt
our Republic.
A phrase may be previously
dismissed as patriarchal.
You risk the original, meaning
bleeding back in.
Precisely, you can't play with
the fire of the founders
language, liberty, self
governance, resistance journey
for too long without its
original radical meaning
starting to to resurface.
The source warns that the
counterfeit oxidizes into the
genuine article.
And for an ideology supposedly
built on careful control and
managerial distance, accidental
sincerity must be terrifying.
What would be?
It means losing control of the
language, losing the ability to
define the terms of the
conversation if people start
taking the words at face value
again.
The source describes watching
this performance as almost
tragic.
Tragic, almost Greek, is the
phrase watching elites who
perhaps just a few years ago
built careers arguing America
was never great, now struggling
to convincingly say God Bless
America without a visible sense
of irony.
Or, you know, an inner cringe.
The performance itself reveals
its own falseness because the
underlying discomfort, maybe
even contempt, for the messy,
unmanaged parts of the nation is
still visible.
That's the claim.
The mask keeps slipping, and the
ultimate prognosis from the
source is pretty grim for the
success of this heist.
Why?
Because the country can smell
the management.
That's the bottom line.
The heist they predict will
ultimately fail, probably
through sheer exhaustion.
Exhaustion.
Yeah, because the lack of
genuine belief simply cannot
sustain such an elaborate high
stakes performance indefinitely,
especially under the intense
spotlight of something like the
two the 150th anniversary, the
effort becomes too much.
OK, so we really dug into the
sources critique of this great
patriotic heist.
The alleged motive, the
strategy, the cultural clash,
the predicted failure due to
inauthenticity.
But like you said, no deep dive
is complete without looking at
the other side.
Absolutely, we need to give the
alternative perspective it's
proper to.
What if this whole pivot isn't a
cynical theft at all?
What if it's actually necessary
evolution or even
rehabilitation?
That counter perspective is
definitely out there and the
source acknowledges it, framing
it as patriotism as self
correction.
OK, self correction, how does
that argument go?
This view argues that the shift
is a kind of rehabilitation, not
theft.
It reframes the critique of
America's injustices not as anti
Americanism, but is actually the
deepest possible expression of
patriotism by appealing to the
nation's founding promise.
The idea is when progressives
point out flaws and demand
change, they aren't rejecting
America.
They're holding it accountable
to its own highest ideals, the
ones written down in 1776, even
if they weren't fully realized
then.
So in this interpretation,
demanding a more equitable
Republic isn't betraying the
nation.
It's showing a deeper fidelity
to the original revolutionary
idea.
It's saying I love this country
enough to demand it live up to
its promise.
OK, and how does this view
explain the suddenness of the
shift, the whiplash?
This counterargument suggests it
might be driven by a pragmatic,
maybe even overdue, recognition.
Moral scolding alone can't hold
a nation together.
A realization that you need
positive vision, not just
critique.
Exactly that they needed a
positive vehicle for achieving
the justice and change they
seek.
And that vehicle ultimately has
to be patriotism itself.
You can't build if you only tear
down.
So if this group, the managerial
class, successfully reclaims
1776, even if they frame it as
unfinished work, then they earn
the right to remake.
It they inherit the
responsibility?
Yes, using patriotism as a
vehicle for justice and reform.
In this view, that's legitimate
inheritance, not theft.
It's the difference between
shouting I hate my family and
saying I love my family.
And because I love it, I demand
we fix these problems.
That's a great analogy for the
shift they might claim they're
making from outsider critic to
demanding insider.
OK, so 2 very different
interpretations of the same
phenomenon, but regardless of
whether the motive is genuine
self correction or cynical
strategy, the source material
seems pretty convinced that the
250th anniversary in 2026 is
going to be a major moment of
truth.
A showdown.
Yeah, the ultimate referendum on
authenticity.
This is where these two
competing versions of America
and American patriotism are
going to clash head on.
How does the source see that
playing out?
They predict a really stark
contrast during the
celebrations.
On one side you'll see the
professional patriotism, the
results of the alleged heist,
meaning the focus grouped flags,
the carefully managed messaging,
the speeches polished by
committees to be inoffensive,
universally approved, maybe a
little sterile.
OK.
The managed version and on the
other side.
On the other side, you'll see
what the source calls the messy,
loud, unfashionable America, the
maybe less polished, more
spontaneous expressions.
The people who still believe the
country is worth arguing about
loudly in public may be getting
it wrong sometimes.
Exactly.
Unafraid of being loud, maybe a
bit vulgar, Definitely not Focus
grouped the raw energy.
The professional manage side
will probably look better in the
official photos and corporate
reports.
Oh, undoubtedly it will have
that sterile Sheen, but the
sources final bet is on the raw,
unfiltered version.
That's the one they believe will
actually sustain belief and last
longer.
Why?
Because it originates in genuine
conviction, however imperfectly
expressed, not in a marketing
plan.
So the ultimate conclusion of
this really powerful if critical
analysis is pretty firm, then
the heist fails.
It fails, they argue, because
authenticity is the only real
patriotism.
You can't actually steal belief.
You can mimic it, but mimicry
always betrays itself
eventually, especially under
pressure.
And a Republic survives it.
Indoors, the source concludes,
not because it's perfect or
because it's elites currently
find it fashionable to praise
it, but because deep down, the
culture still prefers the ugly
truth, the sometimes rude,
vulgar honesty of its people, to
the beautiful lie of managed,
curated public feeling.
A country founded by rebels,
they argue, ultimately can't be
governed by life coaches or
brand managers.
That's the final word from the
source.
A pretty provocative 1.
It really is.
This whole analysis gives us so
much to think about, especially
as we head towards 2026.
So considering everything we've
unpacked today, the history of
patriotism always shifting, the
sources claims about strategic
motives behind the recent pivot,
the arguments about a cultural
DNA that resists management and
that final judgement on
authenticity versus performance.
It's a lot to process.
It is.
So we leave you, our listeners,
with this question.
What does it actually mean for
you to define American
patriotism today?
Knowing, as this analysis
suggests, that the very language
is constantly being rewritten,
fought over, repurposed by
different groups seeking to
control the national story?
How do you decide what that word
truly means?
And maybe more importantly, to
whom does that narrative, that
story of America, ultimately
belong?
A question definitely worth
mulling over long after the
fireworks whether they're.
Real Today we're looking at the
Great Patriotic Heist.
Essentially, it argues, the
progressive left suddenly
pivoted from calling America a
criminal project to grabbing
patriotic symbols.
Right.
Purely strategically, the piece
says to counter the populist
Right before America 250.
It's a really sharp piece, very
dense.
Our aim here is just to offer
some high level thoughts to
maybe enhance its impact even
further.
Absolutely.
The writing itself is fantastic.
Those analogies like plant based
meat for patriotism or the
tenderness of an HR department,
they really land phenomenal
stuff.
The core thesis feels very
solid, so maybe the 1st place to
look in is.
Is the completeness of the
contrast really defining the two
sides?
OK, Yeah, the piece does a great
job painting the managerial
left, the handlers.
It uses these vivid analogies,
you know, Soviet and texture,
that kind of thing.
Really nails their calculated
approach.
It really does.
And to make that contrast hit
even harder, maybe the argument
for the other side, for populist
authenticity, could be defined
by something more than just,
well, temperament, more concrete
political action.
Right now, the critique of the
elite is super specific.
They're the engineers, the
managers trying to fix things
behaviorally.
And the populace, the hustlers,
they come across as, you know,
authentic, maybe course, sink or
swim types defined by affect,
being loud, transparent,
trusting, gut judgement.
That parable about shooting the
intruder?
Exactly that focus on affect.
That's where there might be a
slight vulnerability.
It risks leaving authentic
patriotism a bit too abstract.
How so?
Well, it could open the door to
the criticism that it's just
romanticizing vulgarity rather
than showing a genuine moral
superiority over manipulation.
I see.
If the hustler is primarily
defined as crude, then the
handler can just sort of claim
the high ground of
sophistication, right, And
dismiss, the populist says.
Just throwing a tantrum.
But wait, isn't the whole point
that the populist side is
unfiltered?
That the candor itself is a
moral good against the managed
deception?
Isn't that enough?
It's a strong point, but crude
can be easily dismissed as just
bad manners or maybe a lack of
self-control.
You know, not necessarily a
civic virtue.
OK, so the suggestion here is
maybe to strengthen that
contrast by showing how this
unfiltered patriotism shows up
civically in actual events
beyond just the leader style.
Moving from style to civic
methodology.
Precisely.
So instead of just the
self-defense metaphor, maybe
draw a clearer line showing how
the populist right translates
something like the founders
ordered liberty into a current
non managerial action.
Like what for example?
Well, you could explicitly link
that value they place on, say,
plain speech or irreverence to
specific modern populist
movements or moments.
Show how their lack of Polish,
the opposite of obsessing over
optics, is itself framed as a
defense of the Republic's
original spirit.
OK, so it's not just about being
loud, it's about why they're
allowed civically speaking.
Exactly.
It makes the hustler a figure of
principled resistance, not just
reaction.
It grounds that core distinction
between the Hustler and handler
in concrete actions, proving
it's a method, not just a mood.
That definitely adds weight.
It gives the hustler that civic
virtue needed to counter the
handler's claim to moral
superiority through process.
Right, it shores up that side of
the argument against the very
well defined managerial methods
of the left.
OK, that makes a lot of sense,
so let's pivot slightly.
Talk about the timeline of this
heist.
The piece uses that great
historical contrast, the
spontaneous and 1976
Bicentennial versus the planned
curated 2026 semi
quincentennial.
Yeah, that contrast is
absolutely central, isn't it?
It's the backbone of the
argument.
So how can we make that even
sharper?
Well, one way to sharpen the
contrast between 76 and 26 might
be to lean into those specific
modern academic critiques of the
bicentennial that are mentioned
in the supporting notes.
The idea that critics now see 76
as almost sinister, like proto
fascist.
Exactly.
The essay notes that and
correctly dismisses the
cynicism, but it doesn't fully
weave that critique into the
main argument structure.
Right, I see what you mean.
It's mentioned, but maybe not
fully weaponized for the
argument itself.
Yeah, because, the essay argues,
the managerial class is defined
by this deep fear of unmanaged
affection.
Doesn't.
It it does.
So if the piece can show why
they fear 1976, spelling out
that they genuinely see that
kind of spontaneous patriotism
as, I don't know, a spectacle of
sin, something that ignores
systemic issues, it really amps
up the stakes of the heist.
It makes the appropriation seem
less opportunistic and more like
an ideological necessity for
them to tame that energy.
Precisely, it explains their
motivation on a deeper level.
But hold on, the presumed
audience for this piece probably
already gets the critique of the
managerial class right.
Do we need to slow down and
spell out the opposition's
worldview using their jargon?
I don't think it's slowing down.
I think it's adding structural
tension.
It's about showing the enemy's
ideology more clearly.
OK.
So the suggestion is maybe to
explicitly use some of that
managerial vocabulary.
You know, Colonizer, Original
Sin, Turtle Island, whatever
fits to frame their critique of
76.
Ah, use their words against
them, essentially.
Kind of make it clear that what
the progressives found
problematic in 1976 was
precisely it's unregulated
nature, the lack of control over
the affection.
So you're showing the reader
what the handlers believe
they're saving the country from
by orchestrating 2026.
It justifies the heist in their
own minds.
Exactly.
So when you talk about that 76
spontaneous carnival of belief,
maybe immediately juxtapose it
with the modern critique.
Like the managerial class sees
that carnival not just as tacky
but as dangerous and outburst of
unaccountable affection, the
kind that papers over systemic
injustice or ignores colonizer
history.
I see it demonstrates the heist
isn't just politics, it's rooted
in a fundamental, almost
theological need to manage and
control sincere patriotism.
Right.
It deepens the moral case
against that control by showing
the depth of their ideological
commitment to control.
You use their own framework to
highlight how fundamentally they
disagree with spontaneous
national feeling.
That definitely elevates it,
takes a background point and
pulls it right into the central
conflict.
OK, great, let's move to the
ending then, the piece argues
the heist will ultimately fail.
Yes, through exhaustion, not
violence.
Because no amount of branding
can sustain a love.
You don't feel the counterfeit
oxidizes?
It's a powerful image, that
oxidation.
It is very poetic, but maybe
does the ending need a slightly
clearer consequence for the
handlers?
Failure by exhaustion is maybe a
bit philosophical.
Yeah, maybe a bit.
The assertion is strong, but the
projected outcome could be
defined more sharply.
What does failure mean for them
specifically?
Well, the essay paints them as
trying to redomesticate populist
energy, right?
Using HR like tactics, Civic
love as behavioral engineering.
So what's the worst outcome for
a class defined by control?
Losing control, obviously, but
losing control of what I think
the worst thing is losing their
authority to define reality, to
manage the narrative.
That description of failure, the
stitching shows it's good, but
maybe a touch passive for such
an aggressive piece.
Yeah, perhaps.
For an essay that's pointed, the
failure should probably result
in a more tangible loss, like a
political or cultural loss of
authority for the managerial
class itself.
OK, so connect the failure
directly back to what?
Maybe connect it directly to
linguistic collapse to them
losing the very ability to
curate national morals through
language.
So the failure isn't just that
they feel tired or that the
branding looks fake.
It's an active political
consequence.
They lose their role as the
nation's moral curators.
Exactly.
Their attempt to control
backfires spectacularly, so
strengthen that link between
them appropriating language like
using no kings to mean no
billionaires and how that
ultimately fails.
The piece hints at this, saying
the counterfeit oxidizes into
the genuine article.
Right.
So how specifically does the
language backfire?
What does that collapse look
like?
Well, maybe specify how it
backfires.
Perhaps suggests that the deep
original meaning of the founders
syntax, that core belief in self
rule independence, starts to
seep back through the managerial
disguise.
Like the original programming
reasserting itself.
Yes, the words they tried to
steal suddenly start meaning
what they used to mean,
rendering the handlers careful
spin.
Totally irrelevant, even
counterproductive.
And that transfers credibility
back to.
Back to the loud, vulgar and
free citizens, the ones who
arguably never stop speaking
that original language.
The ultimate failure isn't just
bad PR, it's the public seeing
the beautiful lie for exactly
what it is.
Which collapses their monopoly
on meaning.
Precisely, and with it their
authority.
The failure becomes a decisive
cultural loss for them.
They lose the power to manage
the national story.
That makes the ending much more
active, much punchier.
It loops back perfectly to the
theme of trying and failing to
manage sincere belief, a loss of
authority, not just running out
of steam.
Exactly.
It gives the conclusion the kind
of political bite that matches
the intensity of the rest of the
argument.
OK, this has been incredibly
helpful, really drilling down
into an already excellent piece.
So just to recap the main areas
we touched on for strengthening
the Great Patriotic Heist.
Sure.
First was about fleshing out
that definition of populist
authenticity, giving it more
concrete civic examples, moving
beyond just temperament to
really show it as a form of
principled resistance, making
the hustler a figure of clear
civic virtue.
Right.
Second, leveraging that modern
critique of the 1976
bicentennial, using the
managerial classes own fears and
vocabulary about unregulated
patriotism to really under score
why they feel the need for this
heist.
Raising the ideological stakes.
And finally, sharpening the
ending, defining the failure of
the heist not just as
exhaustion, but as a specific
loss for the handlers, a
collapse of their linguistic
control, their authority, their
monopoly on meaning when the
language they appropriated turns
sincere again.
Great.
These feel like targeted, high
level suggestions that can
really maximize the leverage of
what's already a very forceful
argument.
It's truly sharp, necessary
work.
Agreed.
We strongly encourage the author
to keep refining it.
It's an important piece.
And please do send it back if
you revise it based on this
discussion, we'd be very
interested to see it again.
Definitely we look forward to.
The Great Patriotic Heist.
So what's this all about?
Well, it looks at how the
progressive elite kind of
suddenly flipped, right?
One minute they're calling
America A criminal project.
Flags are props of shame.
The next, bam, they're all about
patriotism.
The source calls this sudden
switcheroo the Great Patriotic
Heist.
Let's dig into why they think
this happened with three main
takeaways.
First, the argument goes, this
isn't some heartfelt change.
Nah, it's purely strategic.
See, the country's 250th
birthday, America 250 in 2026 is
coming up fast.
The fear that rivals would
basically own the whole story of
America.
So boom, a quick two year
marketing Sprint to grab the
flag and push their own
narrative.
Second this new patriotism.
It's described as well,
managerial, think, top down
control, not real feeling.
It's an attempt to rewrite the
script, framing 1776 less about
ordered liberty and more like
some early progressive uprising
against hierarchy.
You know, twisting no kings into
something like no billionaires.
It ends up feeling kind of
forced, like patriotism run by
an HR department, if you get me.
And finally, the piece says this
whole act, it's bound to fall.
Flag because it just isn't
sincere.
American culture tends to value,
you know, straight talk, grit,
getting back up.
It doesn't really vibe with this
managed moral paternalism stuff.
You just can't.
Fake.
Belief, right?
You can mimic it for a while,
but that's not going to last.
So the take away is pretty
clear.
In a culture that values keeping
it real, genuine authenticity is
the only patriotism that truly
sticks.